[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de 7,8 les invités voici les
titres nous recevrons grégory gary
astier maire de la ville de maurepas
nous ferons un point avec lui sur
l'arrivée de migrants dans sa ville en
fin de semaine dernière il conteste
notamment les délais trop courts imposés
par l'état et puis vous entendrez aussi
frederick henderson le nouveau directeur
sportif du club et nous détaillera son
projet pour les templiers d'elancourt
vendredi 4 novembre 99 migrants ont été
relogées dans la salle des fêtes de la
ville de maurepas ils sont arrivés à la
suite de d'évacuation fait place
stalingrad à paris c'est la deuxième
fois que la ville de mort paquet des
réfugiés cela a été le cas au mois de
juillet dernier au gymnase des baissière
une situation qui experts qui exaspère
le maire de maurepas grégory garer ch'ti
étonné qu'aucune autre ville de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines n'ait été sollicités bonsoir
monsieur le gard et astier demain soir
alors pourquoi aucune autre ville n'a
été sollicité pour quoi c'est la
deuxième fois que c'est la ville de
maurepas avez vous la réponse je n'ai
toujours pas la réponse malgré mes
demandes répétées donc voilà j'ai dû
subir cette situation que maintenant
nous sommes en train de gérer avec
l'association qui est sur place alors
dites moi comment avez vous été prévenus
est-ce que c'était dans des lecques dans
les délais dans lesquels vous vous
attendu pas du tout sépare déjà je m'y
attendais pas du tout puisque j'ai voilà
rempli mon devoir d'humanité déjà en
août dernier où pendant près d'un mois
nous avons accueilli à maurepas une
centaine de migrants au gymnase des
baissière qui évite également
réquisitionnés sauf que la situation
était complètement différente on était
dans une période de vacances scolaires
en or là j'ai appris la veille avec un
arrêté du préfet qui est tombé à 19
heures que le même gymnase je n'ai pas
eu à discuter du lieu que le même
gymnase a été réquisitionné pour le
lendemain 8h du matin pour accueillir
une nous une centaine de migrants or
nous sommes en période scolaire et donc
ces trois mille visiteurs par heure par
semaine qui fréquentent l'établissement
1500 adhérents de 17 associations
plus de mille scolaires donc évidemment
en termes d'organisation c'était pas du
tout la même que cet été pour vous la
préfecture gère vraiment mal ce sujet
c'est plus l'état c'est la préfecture
qui est ce qui se passe mais je pense
que c'est l'état à l'état qui n'est pas
du tout dans la concertation avec les
élus locaux et qui impose de manière
autoritaire la gestion de ces
populations qui évidemment sont dans la
souffrance et qui ont besoin d'être
d'être logés d'ailleurs je me pose des
questions comment se fait-il que pendant
plus de 3 mois il était à stalingrad
comment se fait-il qu'ils arrivent sur
le territoire français son camp les
prennent en charge immédiatement ces
pauvres gens étaient dans des tentes
dans le froid et maintenant les ai vécus
dans des bus numérotées dans des
hébergements d'urgence qui ne sont pas
prévus pour cela donc en effet je trouve
que l'état jamais la situation il eu un
véritable bras de fer vendredi un matin
on peut le dire qu'est ce que vous avez
demandé exactement alors je me suis
regroupé avec des élus de la majorité de
maurepas pour évidemment
désapprouvé cette manière autoritaire de
faire de l'état s'est pas l'état après
qui va gérer l'ensemble des 3000
personnes qui fréquentent de toute la
semaine le gymnase qui et qui fait pour
des activités sportives surtout en
pleine année scolaire et donc pendant
plus d'une heure j'ai discuté que
monsieur le sous préfet et au final je
lui ai fait une proposition qui l'a
acceptée c'est à dire d'accueillir ces
migrants à la salle des fêtes de
maurepas qui est un lieu qui est
également adapté qui est également
réchauffer et qui a permis voilà de les
accueillir encore aujourd'hui pendant
quinze jours mais quand vous arrivez
commence à accueillir ce bras de fer il
est étonné qu est ce qui vous dit
comment ça se fait que vous êtes prévenu
le jeudi soir abbas et tu sais quand
vous avez dit c'est unique et c'est une
question à laquelle il répond
évasivement qu'il a des ordres
évidemment de l'état et qui doit les
faire appliquer par souci de solidarité
ce qu'on peut comprendre mais ce n'est
pas une manière de faire c'est déjà
arrivé au mois d'août pourquoi encore
mort pas alors qu'il existe 200 sont de
communes des yvelines et 12 villes sur
saint quentin en yvelines et plus et
plus largement comment se fait-il que il
n'y ait pas eu de réunion depuis avec
les élus locaux moi-même je n'ai jamais
été convié à aucune des réunions pour se
poser réfléchir correctement et de
savoir là où est-ce qu'on peut
accueillir de manière transitoire ou pas
ces populations qui sont dans le besoin
non aucune réunion du coup l'état
fonctionne encore de manière autoritaire
vous parlez de solidarité est-ce que ce
sujet vous en parler avec les maires qui
vous entourent qui entourent n'a vu le
de maurepas ils sont prêts à recevoir
vous vous sentez que ils sont un peu
tatillon dites moi au journal on a ce
genre de discussions mais cette
discussion de se faire aussi avec un
partenaire qui est qui l'état je
rappelle que en moi en tant que maire et
même mon conseil municipal était dû aux
suffrages et au suffrage universel
direct
l'état ce n'est pas le cas donc moi je
suis aussi dépositaire et je suis hors
est responsable aussi devant mes
électeurs et l'état aussi une
responsabilité celle d'assumer sa
compétence régalienne celle d'accueillir
des populations sur son territoire mais
qu'elles le fassent de manière correcte
une mère correct vous avez envoyé une
lettre
même de l'être amenez vos concitoyens
vous avez un devoir que vous allez faire
c'est ce que vous dites à travers votre
lettre vous les avez reçu ça se passe
bien c'est bien perçu aussi par vos
concitoyens ou eux mêmes ne comprennent
pas alors ils ne comprennent pas la
manière de faire de évidemment de l'état
de manière aussi aussi aussi brutale et
j'allais dire mal organisés et ils me
comprennent d'ailleurs je reçois
énormément de messages de soutien du
fait que j'ai pu trouver un compromis
j'ai trouvé un compromis ce n'est pas
l'état qui l'a trouvée c'est moi même en
tant que maire qui est dû gérer cette
situation et de satisfaire également le
quotidien desmaures passe bien en
sauvegardant j'allais dire les activités
pendant quinze jours dans ce gymnase
d'ailleurs ce week-end samedi j'ai
organisé une permanence sur le marché
qui était prévu de longue date et jette
une professeure de danse qui ne veut
voir qui fait au monsieur le maire ont
heureusement vous avez trouvé un
compromis pour accueillir quand même ces
migrants dans un autre lieu parce que
moi j'avais des activités qui sont
évidemment payante et comment j'aurais
fait si j'avais dû annulé tous ses
courts puisque je vis avec ses courants
dont vous voyez donc il ya tout tout
aurait été déstabilisé et donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait une proposition de
les accueillir dans un autre lieu où il
y avait beaucoup moins d'activités qui
était la salle des fêtes alors on a eu
de mariage qu'il a fallu gérer ça s'est
bien passé et maintenant pendant quinze
jours ces populations seront dans cet
établissement est géré par une
association donc ce qui vous pose
problème c'est qu'on ne vous préviennent
pas et pourquoi c'est la deuxième fois
que ça vient
enfin dans votre ville ce n'est pas
cette gestion des migrants que en tant
que non elle est plus connue en ont
quand même vous êtes un bon on est
d'accord il vient bien sûr qu'il faut
remplir notre devoir d'humanité et puis
accueillir des populations qui sont dans
le besoin le débat n'est pas là le naga
et le débat il est est ce que comment
comment on s'organise et comment l'état
s'organise moi ce que je ne comprends
pas c'est comment se fait-il qu'il
existe des locaux vacants sur le
territoire et qui ne sont pas
réquisitionné à deux pas de ma commune
vous avez des locaux d'entreprises qui
sont vides depuis des années pourquoi
est ce qu'ils ne sont pas cartographier
par l'état j'ai posé la question je n'ai
pas de réponse on ne me répond pas donc
je pense que derrière évidemment il ya
certainement d'édition qui sont
politiques encore faut-il qu'on soit
aussi sincère avec nous et ce n'est pas
le cas d'autant plus qu'on parle quand
même d'être humain vous avez des gens
qui sont qui sont dehors qui fuient leur
pays qui sont en guerre la majorité des
populations d'ailleurs qui sont
accueillis à maurepas ce sont des
afghans et des pakistanais
il ya quelques minutes avant que je
vienne voir g t au à la salle des fêtes
pour aller à leur rencontre donc ça se
passe bien finalement ça se passe très
bien mais comme d'ailleurs cet été
l'association qui avait géré habitat et
humanisme ça se passait très bien là
c'est une autre association ça se passe
pour le moment bien avec ses populations
et dont ils sont suivis vous ferez votre
voirie mais là n'est pas la question là
n'est pas la question c'est la manière
dont ça soit comme si si ça recommence
comment s'organise même tous les maires
vous voyez il ya un article du parisien
qui est paru je crois hier ou avant-hier
et on voit bien c'est un problème qui
est trans partisan ça concerne des
maires qui sont les républicains
d'autres qui sont communistes d'autres
socialistes d'autres du centre et donc
tous les maires sont confrontés à la
même situation c'est à dire 7
cet autoritarisme de l'état qui impose
aux maires sans concertation du jour en
lendemain l'accueil de populations ou
bien voulez-vous que ce soit dans une
condition et bien je vous remercie
d'être venu sur le plateau me suis ainsi
investi et on va passer à un tout autre
sujet on va dire un peu plus léger mais
il ya quand même une grande mission est
bien cette mission elle est pour
frederick henderson qui le nouveau
directeur sportif des templiers de
déments cours recruter cet été il est
face à un véritable chantier dernier du
classement l'année dernière il jouait
cette saison en deuxième division
alors comment faire pour redorer le
blason des templiers d'elancourt bonsoir
frederick henderson soir alors c'est
quoi votre projet
donc
merci marbre a invité le projet
est finalement la poursuite de ce qu'on
avait entamé l'année dernière la
restructuration du club
essayer de mettre en place une certaine
cohérence des sections plus jeunes
jusque jusqu'à l'équipe senior histoire
d'assurer
l'intégration des joueurs dans une
filière de performance d'accord donc cet
été j'ai je me suis retroussé les
manches et j'ai mis sur papier
exactement à quoi je voudrais que le
programme ressemble je voudrais comment
je voudrais ressemble et un restructurer
l'association est aujourd'hui bat tous
les jours avec l'aide de tous les tous
les membres de l'association tous les
bénévoles on travaille dit pas on
travaille durement affaires à faire
avancer le projet alors quelles vont
être les changements par exemple est ce
que vous allez avoir un pointeur bac
dernière vous n'en aviez par aesc bas
normalement c'est sûr qu'il va y gagner
on va partir avec le même quarterbacks
jonathan hickman ce
franco-américain king très bonne
connaissance du football et qui est
parfaitement capable de jouer
quarterbacks et de mener l'équipe vers
la victoire
un des soucis qu'on a eu ces dernières
années c'est un gros turn over au niveau
de l'équipe on a beaucoup de personnes
qui ont arrêté on arrive à on a réussi à
remplacer une partie des joueurs qui
ont mis fin à leur carrière avec des
nouveaux joueurs mais effectivement il
faut former ses joueurs donc là d'où
l'u16 les 8-16 qui normalement devrait
perdurer voilà donc dans l'idée du du
projet les joueurs arrivent en u16 on
l'aura en leur enseigne les bases du
football comment pratiquer en toute
sécurité cette activité leur donner les
bases techniques et tactiques pour
ensuite pouvoir évoluer en u19 à mesure
que et c'est qu'ils prennent qui
prennent du galon voilà qui prennent de
la maturité
quand ils arrivent en u19 là l'objectif
plus en plus de valider toutes les tous
les acquis qu'ils ont plus a vendu 16
c'est l'apprentissage de la compétition
comment appréhende bar un environnement
compétitif avec des impératifs de
victoire
c'est quelque chose et que ça sent et
l'île maurice ahrim de budget non
comment ils allaient rémy 10 bat pour
pour l'instant on arrive à maintenir le
budget donc on a toujours le soutien de
la mairie des encours que je remercie
chaleureusement qui met à notre
disposition
locaux et et qui nous soutient dans tous
nos entreprises toutes nos activités
a réussi à manière ce budget là on va
essayer de continuer de travailler à ces
trouver des partenaires privés parce que
ils vont effectivement quand on est
dépendant des subventions publiques les
bacs entier une coupe dans les budgets
et bah ça se ressent au niveau du budget
du club on pourrait éviter d'être en
proie ce genre de soucis l'idée ce sera
d'essayer d'aller démarcher des nouveaux
partenaires pu priver et ses deux
ados de se protéger un peu une forme
d'espèces d'assurance ensemble on assure
une autre entrée de sûrement pas sans
première en allant y ait effectivement
bas il ya cet aspect bien sûr compétitif
dans toutes les activités sportives la
compétition c'est toujours ce qui ce qui
est plus visible après on ad'autres
d'autres axes de travail et c'est
d'intégrer l'association non pas
uniquement en tant qu association
sportive mais aussi associations au sein
du tissu social et économique
de l'agglomération et vous visez donc la
première division effectivement et
je vous remercie d'être venu sur le
plateau c'est vous avez vu c'est très
cool que vous avez pu nous donner votre
message et on espère que là pour que
vous serez en première division l'année
prochaine de l'homme c'est la forme de
ce site huit invités je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée
[Musique]